yo boo like hell podcast episode
number whatever the [ __ ] um
whatever episode it is um technically
second appearance on the podcast because
we did something on zoom with the with
the
with the black soprano fan right right
benny the butcher is here
yes sir i'm in the building this time
though he's in the building this that's
the way we like to do it man i i don't
do zoom for a lot of people we did zoom
for you and uh for action bronson so i i
had to make a couple exceptions right
right right but we got benny here
burton the proof is officially out and
damn hey look man you i feel like yes
sir
the whole crew has been active all year
but you just kind of saved all the ammo
for like the fourth quarter
yeah man i just to be honest with you
because i'm always honest that's
only where i know to be i would have i
would have been put the album out but
it was just so dope that we wanted to
find a home for so we could do something
extra with it so we could do something
special with it
we want to line everything up with it so
that's why we held on to it but we could
have been put this [ __ ] out and i'm
saying
it was a business decision you know what
i'm saying talk about um
because i i was i went to a couple of
the sessions um
when you and hit were working at chalice
on this project
and i remember when hit like he told me
like nah we're gonna do like a whole
situation and i didn't even realize like
hit i knew hit boy was like i'm
of course all-time great producer he's
been a friend of mine for a lot of years
but like
he really got in in his bag like on some
[ __ ] that like
we probably ain't used to hearing him on
like how did the
like the chemistry and the relationship
start with you and hit boy
oh man so just by him reaching out to me
and telling me to come through his work
already gave me an idea what type of
person he was
yeah you know what i'm saying because he
didn't have to do that right right
because this was like
late last year yeah so i come out
uh just kicking it with him i'm saying
he you know he you know him i'm saying
great i'm very humble exactly and i'm
kind of like the same way
and i'm saying so it was like it was
like the synergy was just there you know
what i mean i i enjoy working with him i
love the direction he gave me when we
working on these records i like working
with like producers
instead of like just the beat makers and
i'm saying i i fed off his energy you
know i'm saying he got like
i'm coming through i'm seeing rappers do
their [ __ ] oh yeah everybody be up in
there
like oh [ __ ] see grizzlies here and the
big sean is there yeah i mean right jake
right right right right
i bumped into a whole just a lot of
people there so it's like okay i like
this energy
i'm kennedy my boy he always chilling
through there you know what i'm saying
so
that type of energy there you know i
i like that um you
you mean me and you were talking and we
were talking how this
is your most commercial sounding project
obviously we know griselda and that's
why i think it was so dope for you to
pivot away from like
you know kind of the typical griselda
sound because it you know hey
like it works it's great that's what we
love but i just thought it was dope just
to see you kind of step out of your
comfort zone
um do you how do you feel about
sonically where this album is
and are you afraid of any sort of like
you know
man zelda fans are crazy and they're
extremely like
i feel like they're a little like uh
anytime you have fans that are like that
with cult followings they feel like you
like you're theirs
yeah they feel like they feel like you
know what i'm saying you're theirs they
feel like
you know like we we hope you get to
where you at so don't change you wanna
say no
but i understand where they're coming
from but to be honest with you
i am griselda that's what i'm saying so
i could i
am the griselda sound if i [ __ ]
spit on the song
[ __ ] that's the griselda sound cause i
am griselda i'm benny the butcher one
third of griselda yeah
build this [ __ ] and put it where it's at
you know what i'm saying what i brought
to the table
definitely played a part in to where the
gang got today you know what i'm saying
western just like conway so i don't i
mean
i am griselda so i don't understand it
when they when they say that
they just typically they love that dark
[ __ ] with uh derringer and i'm saying
though that is our chorus sound so they
kind of don't want us to
you know i mean but it's their fault
y'all don't
big y'all don't blow us up so big y'all
the fans y'all did it
y'all don't blow us up so big that you
know what i mean that we getting
different opportunities and
and and let me say this and i was saying
this before the album came up
uh a lot of times we will
cross the bridge but nine times out of
ten when people work with us
they come to your brief act they come on
your side exactly you bring them to your
world so more
of me sounding like the uh the
mainstream artists y'all usually hear
hit boy
work with he's going to sound and i'm
saying he on he on his gutter [ __ ]
because he's a chameleon he's tapping
into his
shoes that's what he didn't do anything
exactly it's a new challenge for him you
know what i'm saying it's like okay
i'm gonna [ __ ] tap in with benny let's
do that let's see
what i mean so and it's worked out
exactly and it's beautiful yeah yeah um
give me for for people who
are we good this is okay now i was gonna
say for people who don't know man
let's kind of like go all the way back
like we all know you're from buffalo
you were you born in buffalo yeah yeah
um
when like kind of give me like a little
background of your childhood man like
how did you come up like what like what
made you first get into rapping and like
what like like how old were you when you
first like really
kind of made the decision to do this
[ __ ] like
um all the way man growing up
growing up was dope man i i i was born
on montana avenue
on the east side i moved to the projects
and it was all we was always having our
cousins over and
always watching tv and watching the
movies and stuff like that so
i always was in love with music like i
used to love wild wild wes
that was my song you know what i'm
saying yeah yeah yeah i used to come on
my mom used to call me like yeah your
song going
you know what i'm saying so i always
loved that we used to stand in right in
front of the tv and just
i mean act out whatever they was doing
in the video you know what i mean so
i always had that love for music when i
was inspired to do it i just
i'm like damn i'm i was above average i
was better than average so
it was something that i wanted to pursue
like when i was about 15. you know it
was it's a group
uh from my hood named killer brown okay
and it's just like older dudes from my
hub when i say older a few couple years
older than me
i grew up with these dudes went to
school with them these are my homies to
this day
they had a rap group called keller brown
from my block montana avenue
and they performed at the apollo they
used to do all the back to school shows
they they uh used to do like regular
shows they uh wardrobe was always put
together so
i come from that you know what i'm
saying it's a long line of that like
from my neighborhood
yeah so we were about 15 you started to
take this rap [ __ ] serious i do i think
that it's important that people realize
like man this
you've put in so much work over the
years and this was not like some
overnight
success [ __ ] like i'm sure at a certain
point in time like how i mean
was there ever a point in time where you
gay like were close to giving up on the
rap [ __ ] because like yo man like
you know it's it's like i said it's a
marathon out here especially being from
buffalo
kind of having that underdog mentality
coming out of that city anyway like
well being a hustler being a hustler
and being so in love with this business
and being so hungry and wanting to
pursue it so bad
i i did have them run-ins in and out of
prison
and i i didn't tell myself that i'm
about to leave the rap game alone i
never said that
but what i told myself is that you know
you might not never like make it big
you know what i'm saying and i was okay
with maybe getting it to a point where
i was just uh making like local music i
mean local money
off of it you know what i'm saying
longer if it was like
maybe you know like 10 bands i'm on off
music i'd have been good i would have
been good with that or maybe even less
yeah as long as i could have made music
and feed my family because i was just so
sick of the
street [ __ ] and all of that so if i
could have made it to that point i would
have been
happy and felt like i was successful so
i didn't never even need all of this you
know what i'm saying yeah i'd be telling
people like if you can like
pay your bills off of music like you're
successful you might not be like
platinum or
like like most people just go to work
every day and do some [ __ ] they hate and
that's how they pay their bills
uh how many you say you you went to
prison a few times what was the longest
stint you did in when you were locked up
two years
two years what year was that was
2000 was it 2000
2003 yeah i was in i was in high school
in 03.
yeah that's where i was supposed to have
been so 03 you did a couple of years
obviously
what what were the what were the charges
uh attempt to distribute
[Music]
lying like like i lied about my name
what's that uh
oh yeah give him false information you
could pull over like yeah i don't got my
id i did it in federal court they
already had me on
i was on a run for some other [ __ ] so
when i got caught up i'm not knowing how
this federal should go like when they
got you they [ __ ] got
you i'm thinking i'm about to lie about
my name and leave some crazy [ __ ]
so i lied about my name they made me put
my
i remember the fake name i gave them
they made me put my hand on the bible
raised my right hand
it's like state your name i stay in my
name i said benny lyman
before i can get my hand down the d.a
was like actually around her
his name is such a send my real name and
there you go new charge damn so they was
just
they they already had you yeah they just
set me up to do that
yeah so you're just gonna be slick when
you was in for two years did was that a
time
because you know we all talk about we we
had a fredo bang in here and he was kind
of talking about how like prison kind of
helped
reset his mentality there i feel like
there's really no you know there's
there's certain ways to look at the
prison [ __ ]
for the most part it really doesn't
rehabilitate anybody but there are
situations in which you know people come
out
with a new mentality like how like do
you think that it helped you at all like
going in there like
i know it just [ __ ] up to say that
anytime i ever
went behind that wall i needed it and
i'm saying you know
the people who watching this interview
they know what kind of people uh
person i am and they know what kind of
person he is if you're watching his
interview if you've ever been to jail
you know you needed it
it's [ __ ] up to say but it's almost
like if that wouldn't happen you might
have died or something
definitely or would it end up doing
something to get more time
you know what i'm saying so you know
everything happens for a reason i'm a
firm believer in that
and i was just young doing [ __ ] not
thinking i'm untouchable
and catching a federal case at 18 you
know how the
the federal case you know that's that
[ __ ] you got to do what 70
of the time no matter what right it's a
fake case it's something like that they
change it every time
right right right uh you know they come
with they [ __ ] so it's like
if the feds are coming at you it's not
like yo man like good luck
that means that they're not they're not
coming at you unless they got you
exactly nine times out of ten so so
after going through that like i would i
kind of knew more like man you better
if you doing that you better boy because
when they come they go you know or i
knew
certain people who had a fair case and
they're like okay i got this case i'm
about to do this i'm like no don't do
that
because they will lose you i'm saying
you'll never see a family again
so i knew even though i was higher
headed still at times but
i still had to i got to learn from that
so you had to you had to do fed time
those two years
was that uh i heard are federal prisons
supposed to be like nicer than other
ones
yeah yeah okay boom i wasn't i ended up
going to a camp a federal camp i was in
there with emory emery jones okay yeah
it was in the same federal camp
and uh basically i remember i got to us
i got to i got to the atlanta usp
and uh i was talking to my bunkie he was
telling me about the atlanta camp he was
like yeah
yeah i was at the camp and you know what
i mean i went to the mall i left anytime
i leave in a
prison and going to a mall and i'm like
i'm not even paying attention because
they don't even sound real so i'm
thinking like
it's just cat or whatever so i end up
making it to
a spot a camp and people are leaving the
jail
it got a gate around it but it's like no
gun towers
and it's got and it's like the perimeter
is next to a medium
medium security prison and it's a camp a
minimum security prison you know i'm
saying for people who said who who's on
their way home
right right right what i'm saying uh
emory was there at the end of his bed
uh so yeah people delete a [ __ ]
that's what people do
and i left my baby mama came i left i
got some [ __ ]
i brought [ __ ] back into jail and
everything had a cell phone all type of
[ __ ]
jordan's henny everything so you could
have
well first brought in a bazooka so at
that point in time they're not
considering that [ __ ] contraband or did
you have it tucked
hell yeah they didn't know we had that
[ __ ] where do you hide a bottle of
hennessy
uh to be honest with honest with you we
held it
okay first it's a team of us right right
shout out my man sam man
my man sway my man uh just those are
dudes i was locked up with
uh sam man he used to he used to be like
a porter
he said he used to like do the trash
yeah so he's like hide the [ __ ] under
the trash can he's the only
person who trusts who touched the trash
on the unit so he used to hide the [ __ ]
under the trash under the trash lining
yeah hell yeah so we did it was glass
bottle though so what the [ __ ] is glass
doing on the prison comments
right right right after we drink the
bottle he put the
glass in the pillowcase break it up
break it up real fine
and dispose of it hell yeah
she's crazy but damn that's crazy so you
got to leave get [ __ ] bring [ __ ] back
in
it was kind of like you know like i mean
that [ __ ] sounds
that's just sound crazy now mind you
even though this is a camp this is still
pretty
it's still prison it's still a [ __ ]
prison so it's people in here who who
who've been in here for 20 years who
never did no [ __ ] like that in 20 years
it was just [ __ ] like that in there
who just wanted this for me to tell the
story okay oh yo
young blood so you saw her i heard you
left yesterday
man how was it out there can i smell
your fingers
[Laughter]
real like these [ __ ] they can't
believe i was just out there like that
you know yeah yeah
back in here these [ __ ] been down for
20 joints that's crazy hey
so you said you were locked up with
emery did you guys have a relationship
when you were locked up together
emory you know he was a dude everybody
bothered emory because they knew
it was like yo this i mean they knew
that was hoes man when we know when this
[ __ ] got home
he was going to be here even though of
course he came in he came home and he
worked for his and he became for sure
his own man
oh for sure i mean yo man like like you
know
obviously we don't really know exactly
what happened but he kind of you know he
took that on the
on the chin for the big homie definitely
definitely
uh you know i mean i really like mmm
live you know what i'm saying
but we knew of each other we knew who
each other was so like were you
because in prison you know
where like were you like known as a
rapper there like were you like were
there cyphers going on
like or was it something that you did
you just kind of like
didn't advertise to people man hell yeah
i advertised that's nothing that i
couldn't hide
see now in a federal prison they got
things that they call cars
they take you they take you to whatever
state you from
when you get on the compound they're
like where you from i say buffalo they
like okay we'll take you to the
until we'd take you to the new york car
so that's what they did they took me to
the new york highways [ __ ] from
brooklyn highlands
you for what i'm saying uh even though
new york is
is one place you already know how that
is it's territorial you know what i'm
saying
you know [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
how new york [ __ ]
they look at me like this [ __ ] from
buffalo buffalo exactly
so i caught that vibe you know i mean
and then i just i really
just was on my own you know i mean for a
second
until [ __ ] see me coming back with
that big bag of commissary all the time
they see that i mean they see i'm moving
with a certain way so you know [ __ ]
get in my business they start talking to
me then
about prison once you it's about opening
up doors in prison
when i first get to jails i never let
nobody i used to never let nobody know i
rap because i know i'm about to wrap my
ass off and then the whole jail gonna be
on me yeah so
i took i took like two months off before
letting people know i rap
because nine times out of ten i'm always
like the most professional rap [ __ ]
here
now to walk throughout all of this i had
a video
do the time in jail i had a video on bet
uncut so i was always the and i mean the
most professional i had fliers i had all
type of [ __ ] cds and
so [ __ ] like oh no he really rap you
know i mean so it's nothing that i
they and this one jail they had a spot
where [ __ ] wrapped every friday night
so everybody would just be in there just
going going in
every friday night when there's a meet
up on this comment to be a whole bunch
of [ __ ] in there right
i went to that [ __ ] like three times
buried that [ __ ] and didn't go for the
rest of the time i was at that jail damn
that's crazy
so you're in prison this is 03.05 ish
let's just say that ballpark um
can you talk about because i you know i
have my
my history with taking l's in life and
what is the biggest l you ever took in
the streets do you remember
whether it was something that got caught
up in the mail or
you know i you know there's different
ways that things can get
um well now
when this happened i was locked up but
this is the team
i'm saying when i before i go to jail we
was moving doing what we do and then i
got this new
and i'm only i'm only in jail for a
violation so i'm about to come back home
so i i leave the the organization
yeah and i go to jail and then i hear
the news like ah
man i'm like [ __ ] so when i like come
home we're like starting from scratch
uh basically like yeah like 100 pounds
[ __ ]
it's crazy too because being in la and
just kind of knowing like what packs
will
move for like you'll probably get the
most for a pack
in [ __ ] buffalo yeah hell yeah hey yo
the person who got caught with that is
probably still on probation for that
[ __ ] right now that's a lot of weight
man
yeah for real would you guys ever come
out it was a female too
oh yeah that's i mean she held it down
that's kind of the go-to right
you get to check this down and you know
she held it down and it
wasn't her first rodeo neither um and
then
the forming of griselda you being
officially involved with griselda like
fast forward you get out of prison when
when when was that something that like
you know kind of started to like become
like official
or the grizzly thing yeah uh
it's a whole different time i'm coming
out this is later
yeah yeah okay uh
wes and conway and me we always been
doing our thing for years
it's just evolved into different things
like we was all [ __ ] with dj shay
rest in peace yeah rest in peace dj shay
it was all assigned to shay
and then i kind of like stayed with shea
but i kind of like i was with shay's
company then i kind of like brought shea
into my company i learned a whole lot
from him
i kind of like he he like learned from
learned so much from him he like
catapulted me to start my own [ __ ]
and he just helped me uh same thing with
uh western conway they was doing
they own [ __ ] over there but we was
always doing songs together
in like 2016.
that's when i noticed it 2015. okay
that's when i noticed
what the [ __ ] they had going on but
around that that happened to them and
you know people asking me this question
but
i was brought in on griselda i'm saying
by the time
wes brought me in the shady deal was
right there you know what i'm saying
i was put in on that when he knew he
when he found out he's about to get the
shady deal he like oh [ __ ] let me go get
my cars
you what i'm saying so he put all the
pain in to get to that point you for
what i'm saying him in conway
so when i got brought in around that
time uh
2016 i was just hungry ready to go you
know what i'm saying yeah i feel like
you were kind of you know watching those
freestyles back then
like you know i just remember i forget
which i think it might have been on
static show you had the [ __ ]
sean mccoy on you had the buffalo bills
hat and i was like
you know obviously it was about gun and
conway at the time and then like yo this
dude benny is
crazy and i almost felt like every time
you had the opportunity
you were like yo i gotta i gotta like
show my ass on these [ __ ] freestyles
that's what it was and them dudes always
motivated me to do that before like yeah
you know you gotta kill this [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying yeah
yo um the i feel like
tana talk three was such a very
important
moment in your career um i feel like
that
you you were putting out dope projects
prior to that but i feel like that that
was like the project where like
you really like started to really like
step into your own
as far as acknowledgement in the
industry you know what i'm saying like
um do you remember like
that like that album coming out like did
you have the feeling that
like things were going to change after
that because it felt like that album
comes out obviously plugs i met
was really that project but i feel like
10 talk 3 was like
kind of your coming out party if that
makes sense
yeah and that's what happened for but
did i see it
yes and no i see i didn't see it because
this is all
uncharted territory for me i don't i
really don't know what to expect
you for what i'm saying i know conway
doing good numbers i know wes says
like i said they brought me in that
don't mean i'm a you know what i'm
saying
so but i did believe it because you know
[ __ ] was telling me that like yo watch
watch the montana talk three drop watch
this i'm telling you about everybody i
played that for
before it came out had the same reaction
as when it came out like yo
yo this [ __ ] is crazy so that having
that tape done for about
a year or so before it came out i played
it for everybody
and my confidence was already up before
it dropped because i played it for
people for a year
played it for uh ray when he was playing
it uh
used to play play some [ __ ] for royce
just played played it around my uh my
peers and [ __ ]
and everybody [ __ ] with it now i
remember green lantern like telling me
pretty early like yo like conway's dope
like benny's like
special special and yeah well like i
feel like that
that project really kind of solidified
kind of your path that you're on right
now and obviously
plugs i met is a [ __ ] classic that's
my [ __ ] though i mean it's a classic
that's my [ __ ] i don't say that very
lightly no right right right you can't
call and i mean that's a classic project
and and on that project one of the best
i mean dude the record with push is like
one of the best coke rap songs ever
created like it's like [ __ ]
it's like all like it'd be like if
somebody was like i'm gonna cut you off
i tried to call that song
uh drug dealer anonymous too
yeah they ain't let me you know i mean i
sent it to get
i sent it in turned it in the label they
and they caught and i think somebody
from somebody's eye was like
yeah you can't do that don't call it
that and i'm like [ __ ] 18-wheeler
18-wheeler of course when did you when
you wrote your verse for that record did
you know push was getting on it
so you kind of like you like that you
were like yo i got to come with that
talk
that's one of the that's uh one of the
few records that i knew the person was
getting on
when i did the joint but i did i knew
that for black thought too
so you gotta when you know black thought
and push are getting all two different
records yeah yeah yeah those are jedi's
man right so that's why i wanna know why
i'm rapping like that on them songs
because i know what i know where them
shit's just landing at
you feel what i'm saying so i remember
hitting push up
yo i needed it he's like nah i got you
i'm like oh [ __ ] i'm like yo load this
up shay
i did that [ __ ] immediately fire um
we were talking too like how
disappointing it had to be you were
supposed to go out on the road with russ
you're on russ's album
um you know shout out to russ for just
giving so much free game and
and i think shout out to the big dog
russ man russ a great dude but like uh
how did that happen like russ and benny
on a record
when that track listing dropped i was
like i want to listen to that song what
are some of the wrong song
you know what i'm saying but like wait
like obviously you respect you as an mc
and russ
doesn't get enough love for his
capabilities as an emcee as well
he don't we we listen we actually got a
record i don't know when he gonna drop
this record
[ __ ] russ
benny and black dog
and it's just gone we just and we both
like we are rapping
long wow what i'm saying it's almost
like a five six minute song
wow everybody's rapping long it's a
crazy song
wow i feel like it's gonna be a moment
when it come out
damn that's crazy yeah people did he
just tapping with you on dm
because he's obviously a fan of your
[ __ ] yeah yeah you know what i'm saying
you just tapped me
on the dm like russ don't get enough
credit for like his lyrical abilities
for sure
the guy can do anything exactly so and
he gives free game to everybody
so no matter where hi the career path
no matter what no matter where that took
him he still got the
uh ability that he got so he could
notice it in others you see what i'm
saying so
a person don't got to be all big and
nothing like that he just reaching out
for the sport of it like i like this
dude yo we should work so
shout out to russ cause i love when
[ __ ] do that and and help
[ __ ] with opportunities and i do the
same thing and i'm saying i reach back
too
i mean listen we talked about this on
zoom but you know
two records in the camera with drake two
so that's a i mean listen you just
dropped an album that's just got to come
out
ross and wayne and shawn are you talking
about them all the time
the drake records i mean like we we
think of
how many times that guy's jumped on
someone's records and changed their life
right you already got your own [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying but like to have
drake like who whose hands
is it in for those records to come out
is it in his hands is it in your hands
is it like what like
i'm assuming one's coming out with his
[ __ ] one might come out on your [ __ ]
like
whose hands is that in oh yeah that's
that's the plan uh
he pulled one out and i put one out you
know what i'm saying uh even if
but trust me i feel like because you
know at the end of the day this is a
business
you know what i'm saying it's records
that i didn't put on my album because
it wasn't it wasn't cohesive with the
album not saying that the records was
bad records are crazy i can't wait to
put them out on something else
but maybe if people don't get those
records i'm pretty sure they get they
get a record with bro you know i'm
saying with me and broken i'm saying
i feel like it's something that he want
to do but i feel like i'm on
did you body drake i had i don't think i
have hell no
did he this i mean drake's a smart guy
he's obviously a fan of you so he has to
come
with his a plus game to hop on a record
with benny
because you know the discussion will be
like yo benny wash drake
that's what the first thing people
people are going to go to is be like
him who got who i'm not gonna lie he's
he's like one of the most
like comfortable person like he's a jedi
yeah you know what i mean so he's like
he's he's sent his verse first like
a lot of times dudes be scared someone's
working on it already
because they they feel like what you're
going to do when you come at me he's
confident he's like huh
i mean what you're going to do what i'm
going to do exactly you know i mean and
i like that type of energy and that just
let me know a lot about him and he
he i mean he played his game the right
way are there hooks on either of the
records are we just talking straight
bars
um i think direct the record that i got
control of
without that that he letting me rock
with is bars on there
and i'm saying the other one is it's
bars too i'm already talking too much
y'all going to get these soon baby
listen we just we're talking too because
i think that everybody's waiting for you
and jay-z to work together ever since
the roc nation thing
yeah there they are everybody was
everybody was thinking hov was going to
be on burden of proof
i was saying it in the comments i'm like
yo i hate to let the people down when i
especially when you put the tape over
the name
when you drop them because the big sean
verse happened i didn't
i heard that record without sean on it
so that sean verse is rather recent
right
yup yup yeah cause hit boy played me
that record and just had wayne on it you
people just knew it was whole i kind of
think
people knew i mean i kind of think like
we knew people was going to think that
so that's why it's like yo take the name
out put the tape on it
let's troll the fans like we played into
that yeah for sure
um is that something that like obviously
everybody wants to do a song with jay-z
everybody does um you have a direct line
with hove like you
but you also don't want to be the guy
that just asks for the verse you kind of
want it to just happen
yeah of course i wanted to just happen
but i'm not gonna lie i act as a big
homie for the verse
because it's like you cannot like not
ask for the first still like you gotta
let them know like yo
you know i mean but it's something that
was gonna happen i was saying this
if i was to get a whole verse i would be
the
the person who got one the quickest hope
don't hand verses out like that and he
don't hand them out that quick
when people get a whole verse you're
already a legend
solidified in the game by the time you
get the verse nine times out of ten
and i'm not at that point yet you know
what i'm saying maybe
i don't know what i'm saying maybe i
don't know i know i know that he want to
do it because we spoke about it
yeah but is the time is the time right
maybe not facts
um you were one of the only people who
nes who weren't necessarily when the
griselda thing happened
you were not officially on shady right
so conway
uh you know uh westside and uh
and the griselda project came out
through shady but you necessarily you
didn't have that shady
like label backing like right did eminem
try to sign you later on
after [ __ ] kind of started to get moving
like was that was that
were there ever any discussions of you
coming over to shady officially
definitely definitely uh uh shady
records try to pursue me after
after did you kind of like like like
what made you kind of pass on that was
it the fact that they didn't see it from
the jump
um no i never took it personal because
i i immediately understood the business
of it but
i kind of like i i kind of like knew
what the
being under the shady umbrella was and
then it was like we was already under
there so like maybe
let me get over here so we know i'm
saying or go wherever i want to put all
your
like don't put the cruise eggs in the
same basket that's what i'm saying no
that's fair
it would talk about the friendly
competition between u-gun and uh and
conway because i feel like it's
definitely there like you guys are all
you know especially you and conway on
the mc side but like
quality of music all three of you guys
are out of here pray for paris one of
the best albums of the year
guns dropped three projects this year
you're about to drop your second
um conway dropped two but [ __ ] three
projects this year
yeah yeah um but like is the competition
it seems very healthy and you guys are i
always
whenever you guys drop some [ __ ] and
there's like those quintessential like
posse cuts like spurs three or whatever
it is like that's like my first record i
go
right right but like is it is it
competition and is it like has it ever
been to the point where you're like [ __ ]
like i got god on this record like i
feel like
when you have three artists on that
level of rapping
you know it's gotta it's gotta be like
steel sharp and steel yeah
no no is it is it competition i can't
look up here and say it's not
competition right
and i'm saying but trust me it's healthy
competition and it's not like
devious competition right right right
right it's like
uh you know you know what khan we're
gonna do
so you wanna and i mean so you wanna you
wanna bring your [ __ ] too
and we go to the we go to the shows you
know what i'm
saying like what the what the [ __ ] this
[ __ ] be saying
he was like uh you know they get crazy
loud for west side gun [ __ ]
yeah you for what i'm saying they get
crazy loud so it was like he's like the
paul heyman of the crew
yeah exactly exactly so it's just like
everybody
bring their own [ __ ] but man when i hear
the people loud at
the shows for uh wes i want them to be
loud for me
and i'm saying when i see the comments
yo conway drop the classic
i want my [ __ ] to be classic too of
course i mean so it's like it's that
type of [ __ ] and it's almost like you
know
just trying to keep up with each other
and [ __ ] yo look man quick break from
the podcast and tell you about odd socks
all right they're our official sponsor
they support what we do here at the
bootleg kit podcast
all right they got them nickelodeon
joints they got these uh
yo shout out to ghostbusters i might
keep those um anyway
what you got to do is hit that
oddsoxofficial.com
if you want to support what i do the
bootleghead podcast then support our
partners odd socks go buy some socks man
holidays are coming up odd
socksofficial.com
keyword bootleg kev you're getting 20
off of the most comfortable socks in the
world
shout out to odd socks yo um
would you have you and fred ever talked
about doing an ep together
hell yeah hell yeah cause you and
freddie we just had that discussion in
there and it was like yo
like this [ __ ] is like it has been a
very long time
we have kendrick we have drake we have
cole it's been a long time since we've
gotten another one of those guys on that
mount rushmore and we were just talking
like you and fred
are like i feel like
got that chance and fred's obviously og
was on the 2010 freshman cover
yeah fire yeah and and we know we know
we wear them shoes in the game
and it's just dope to be mentioned like
that before what i'm saying to be
mentioned with the likes and be
mentioned in the uh
in that type of manner of being on a
mount rushmore but
but you and fred i feel like y'all got
great chemistry i know he [ __ ] you're
one of the few people in the industry
that he actually likes
no that's not he's an [ __ ] that's my
[ __ ] boy i'm saying that's my boy and
we talk about that all the time we need
to make that happen i'm gonna call him
when i finish this [ __ ]
we need to make that happen i'm saying
little quick ep just something
for the fans for the street so we have
fun doing it we had so much fun
um all right so burton proof is out and
we've talked we i mean i've heard you
talk about tana talk four plugs i met
too
um i know i've heard you say maybe
like what plugs i met too is that what's
next on the
and is it done everything done every
record is clear every sample is clear
on it uh everything is done except the
whole verse
obviously the plugs i made too
everything was done
before burn the proof that's what i'm
telling people is like i could have
dropped that
i held off on purpose you know what i'm
saying because you know the fans be
thinking and they get not in the studio
but like i held off that been ready i we
was really
like moments away from pressing a button
on plugs i met too
but it was like uh let's catch this
lightning in the bottle real quick and
then go
catch that lightning bottle too can you
kind of give me some of the uh
some of the game on your merch because i
feel like rappers who are watching this
thing like they might be able to get
come up on some game with what y'all are
doing in the merch game and
like what's the most y'all have ever
like what's the most you've made on a
merch drop in a month
not to be in your pockets but you know
for inspirational purposes
the most i ever made was like 400 000.
400k
on a on on a was it a hoodie was it a
shirt or what
shirts [ __ ] is crazy mm-hmm
four hundred thousand hell yeah
did you you you just did it i just did a
merge drop a couple days ago i know
shout out those hoodies are for the
pyrex hoodies yup yup
go grab those grab those joints fire
yeah i was so mad when i went to the
[ __ ] la show out here because the
only thing that was left was like
something you had for sale for 400
or something i was like [ __ ] man i think
it was like a jacket or something or
something like
right right [ __ ] butcher like [ __ ]
apron or something
damn yeah it was kind of crazy man um
all right so we're gonna get plugs on
that two next
yeah that's coming next that's coming
next um i got i got
fat joe on there two chains on there
french montana on there
jim jones on there it's crazy obviously
you have black soprano family um
conway's got drum work music um
griselda's you know obviously you know
family but like
how important it is how important is it
for you to build your own
imprint because you know the [ __ ]
mixtape was fire shout out dj drama
shout out to the whole crew
shout out to to rick hyde but like how
important is that for you to kind of
like
i'm not saying break away from zelda but
like have your own identity that's
uh outside of griselda uh it's super
important
you know i'm saying it's super important
in an aspect of
not me trying to have my own identity
but uh
being in the position that i am i got a
responsibility and i'm saying
and and and black soprano family
it's really the family and these are all
dudes who
are extended griselda family like i seen
rick hi may make a tweet
the first time i met rick hyde was with
conway he came in they both freestyled
on my show
he came up with conway exactly you know
what i'm saying so uh
rick hyde like recorded dr birds he
recorded like
what i'm saying so he he's just like
family so they all had their own
relationships with griselda and
you know we like people compare us to
the wu-tang clan and we kind of are like
the wu-tang clan cuz yeah we got a whole
bunch of different [ __ ] and
rick hyde just been around forever
raheem and uh conway damn they're from
the same hood
you know what i'm saying he's from the
same hood so it was like
i mean this is just extended family and
these are dudes who
these are dudes who watched us
make it to where we made it and got the
opportunity now to
to be a part of it you for what i'm
saying so it's super important that i
take the responsibility
uh seriously and make a way so my some
sort of guys who helped me get here
could eat too um i think everybody asked
you know the top rappers question but
give me your top five albums off the top
of your head
this isn't like a cement list just what
are the five albums that come come up
okay okay uh i gotta go
i gotta go reasonable doubt
okay my favorite hove album i gotta go
i gotta go uh
uh
we are the streets the cox album the
locks yup
i love that album uh life after death
big
um and i gotta go nice i
am interesting i am
i am i am the third album
i am i am i'm going to tell you the
story behind that because i i get that
reaction all the time
because i feel like it's either it was
written or illmatic is everyone's answer
but i am
is i am when i came out that's when i'm
understanding music
so i went back to those you know what
i'm saying that's when i'm under i'm 14.
i remember buying that album vividly i
bought that in tlc's fan mail the same
way as a kid
all came out at the same time i remember
99 i remember that
and i mean what's the fifth one man i
would have to say the fifth one is
butcher on steroids go check that out if
you never heard the butcher on steroids
go hear that
people always ask me what's my best
album i can never pick
i heard i listened to that the other day
and i had to stop i had to be real with
myself
butchering steroids is some of my best
best
work i'm saying that [ __ ] is up there
but you're on steroids butcher on
steroids with green lantern
yo shout out to green man hey um
you you know what i love about what you
guys do is like you guys will do a whole
project with hit boy or a whole project
with alchemist
you know what i'm saying like mad madly
whatever the [ __ ] right
uh is there any other producer that you
would like to lock in with for that kind
of
you know the hit boy [ __ ] is crazy burn
the proof out now go support it but is
there another producer outside of
derringer outside of kind of
that you would want to lock in with on i
think you and primo would be crazy
that's what i was about to say i want to
lock in with prem
man i want to lock in with uh
9th i want to lock in
with just just to be crazy you know what
i mean
ain't gay too i'm saying if you're going
to get elected president maybe you have
some time are you voting for
can you vote uh yeah i can vote i'm not
voting yeah you
you know i was talking to conway and he
was kind of explaining to me the
like you know his trip to wyoming and
all that [ __ ] did you
like your relationship with kanye is
there one there is there
was that more him and gun or yeah that
was more him a gun
but shout out yay though and i'm saying
because they invited me but i mean that
was more i think he like
him they did something together but i
was more him a gun can you talk about
because i know you got to get out of
here the rock nathan the roc nation guy
is waving
waving at me the man with the ponytail
um
real quick man because i i think uh it's
important for anyone who's listening or
watching this to kind of
for inspirational purposes man you you
know i just saw your daughters like
going to college
right like you're a [ __ ] father
you're
um i want i want you to kind of give me
you know your take on the perseverance
that it took for you to get to this
point because i think a lot of people
look at you as a new artist and look at
you
like man like you a grown-ass man with
real ass responsibilities in this world
and like you're just hitting your peak
and
i think a lot of people they're
they're in it for the quick nut and once
something doesn't happen that they
expect to happen as quick as they'd like
it to happen they give up and they walk
away and
question what they do like like your
career
as a whole kind of you know what what
drove you the whole time man and like
just my hunger for it and uh
knowing i had the talent i always felt
the responsibility to my talent
because even when i was in and out of
jail or even i was on
corners trapping or even i was serving
[ __ ] who who wanted who was my fans
like yo man you you still rapping and
i'm like damn i was just in the studio
earlier [ __ ] asking me am i still
rapping
i thought i had [ __ ] on lock you know
what i'm saying in town when they asked
me i'm still rapping
so i always felt that i always had to
answer that and i
feel like uh far is my perseverance and
everything is like
people here hear it but they don't they
don't really take it for what it's worth
everybody want to do the cute [ __ ]
nobody literally want to get in this
game have discipline
you from saying discipline themselves
and learn the business you know what i'm
saying that's the hard part nobody want
to do [ __ ]
these [ __ ] selling all these records
they still don't know the business they
don't know they still don't know [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying
get on tv and they look like experts
these these [ __ ] don't know nothing so
i did everything step by step because i
couldn't
get in the records from drake and push
and all them [ __ ] in that
wayne that wasn't an option for me
always so wow you had to earn that
exactly
exactly so i did it step by step i
really did it the hard way and you know
dudes don't want to do it no more but
it's the most
that's the most valuable way to do it
because
uh it's always going to be there if you
put a brick on top of a brick that's
what i'm saying is still you're going to
go exactly so it's like
this is something physical when i when i
know what i'm doing this is physical
because the knowledge never go nowhere
you know what i'm saying the experience
that you got from that hard work can
never go nowhere
and i felt like i just had the
discipline and i tell
i tell my team that like the number one
thing is
you got to have discipline not enough to
to hang around those dudes who can get
you on some [ __ ] when you can't be
here
you got to have enough discipline not to
take the easy money over here when they
offering it to you
you got to have a discipline and not to
be over here [ __ ] with these [ __ ]
over here instagram [ __ ]
screenshot your messages and all that
weird [ __ ] you got to have discipline in
this game and that'll get you fired
when i was talking to conway we were we
were talking and he was like you know
when it comes to the griselda you look
at it like it's a body
i'm the heart gun is the brain
and benny's the muscle mm-hmm um
what can you give me one thing what's
the biggest thing that you've learned
from gun
because i feel like he is a genius i
feel like we have
we have seen very few people come
through this music industry that have
have his understanding of marketing he's
just he's just a smart dude man and a
friend
right right i learned a lot of i learned
a lot of marketing from him
uh obviously i learned i learned
a lot of just just do it it's just about
doing it like you can do what you want
to do
there's no blueprint for this [ __ ] do it
you got an idea do it
and i'm saying uh what else
i mean just just [ __ ] like that will
there be another griselda album hell
yeah
for sure oh yeah hell yeah what was she
in gun too i heard
i'm saying i think you want to call it
that what was she going to do too what
was she going to do too
you guys got to have so many [ __ ]
records just yes we do
yes we do hey i want to i want to i need
to drop the me and the benny and conway
project like that's what really what we
need that's what the fans want that's
what the fans
want dogs for real and me and conway we
talked about it before too
you know you know [ __ ] got their
obligations and it kind of was going to
get in the middle of the obligations not
saying that we gave a [ __ ] about that
i would say it's kind of cool you guys
are each independent exactly
like you know i know conway's got a
shady album that's supposed to come out
for the end of the year
but like yo no we talked about when we
talked when we talked about it then
how many how many songs do you guys have
you guys like have you guys officially
worked on records for that project or
has it just kind of like
been talked about oh it's been talked
about so you guys haven't like
like i think it should be you conway
and just pick a producer to do the whole
joint whether it's derringer
i think it really should be derringer
just for the financial too i think so if
it's gonna be youtube
it should be darren sure just do it for
the fans bro yeah we wouldn't have it no
other way that we
of course would do it with derringer and
uh we we haven't done that because like
that's a three four day thing you know
how the griselda projects be we get we
get together and we lock the [ __ ]
have you guys talked about a name or
anything yeah you guys will sell so much
[ __ ] merch when that [ __ ] drops
shout out to conway hey man benny i
appreciate johnny you got to get out of
here
album is out burden the proof go support
it uh
plugs i met two coming before the end of
the year it's on the way plugs i made
two
before 2021 uh no no no no no before
twenty yeah
we go on top of january on that okay the
pressure is up i told people a couple
months ago
after june or july is everything is mine
i've been killing features i'm about to
i'm about to uh be smoking [ __ ] with
this burden of proof and i'm i'm
doubling back
boom benny appreciate you bro i love my
boy
let's go